hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the European
individual championship 2019 in Scorpio
and it's a game between a vada Slav
artemyev and andreas panko so it's a
game from the penultimate round from the
final round even though the final round
already finished but we are gonna get
back to that after we check out the game
now I don't know if you remember some
two years ago I believe it was maybe
2017 World Championship
Andres Banco created that beautiful
miniature against Serbia Kyra can I will
put a link to it in the description
below if you haven't seen it it will be
the first thing you will see in the
description ball so do check it out it's
quite a quite a masterpiece but this is
a bit of a different game I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it so let's just dive
straight into it
Artemyev has the white pieces and he
opens with Knight to f3
we have Knight to f6 g3 g6 bunch of g2
and Bishop to g7 so everything
symmetrical with d4 d5 by black and both
players Castle and here with c4 Artemyev
transposes into the neo Broomfield we
have d captures on c4 and now white
wants to recapture the pawn we had nice
to a3 and black decides okay I will give
you back the pawn but in a way that I
see fit so he simply pushes the pawn to
c3 to give it back this way white
recaptures and now black gave white a
nice Center and now of course he wants
to attack it with the defiant point we
have rook to e1 by our Tammy of
preparing e4 Knight to c6 and now we do
have efore so as you can see as it is
often the case in in any room for
defense white will have a very strong
center and black will try to attack the
central with with the sides from let's
say the C pawn with the Knight Bishop
also will join in with an attack against
the center and so on
seek a person DeForest played by AC
panco see captures on d4 and now Bishop
to g4 thinning that night and here we
have Bishop to b2 challenging blacks
dark square bishop so now it's not going
to be all
that all that impressive and also
defending the the d4 pawn with nice the
d7 by black and here this exact same
position was on the board in 2015 in the
Women's World Chess Championship in
Sochi Russia and again between
Antoinetta Stefano and and mosaic Maria
I believe I know animals each oak and
most Mucha won that game in the that
game black played white white played
nice to see to this was the move that
white played and the white lost that
game but here white plays rook to be won
this is a new move artemiev and it is
now from 13 that we have a completely
new game on the board so it seems a
Artemyev definitely brushed up under
under roomful theory here okay we have
night the b6 and d5 now as now a lot of
pressure is projected towards the d4
pawn so here are Tamir grabs more space
in center while also offers a trade of
dark square bishop we have Bob character
some be to rock out for some b2 and now
comes Knight to e5 with a double attack
on the night here the knight is pinned
since the bishop is still painting it so
here artemyev on pins we have Queen to
b3 and then now Bishop captures on f3
Bishop captures and now comes Knight to
a4 a very sneaky move whereas if white
captures the knight just Knight captures
here will win the game as it wins the
exchange so after Knight to a4 rook to
c2 Artemia just moves the rock out of
the way Knight characters on f3 with
Czech Queen captures on f3 is played in
the now rook the c8 offering a trade off
of rooks we have rook eat the c1
Artemyev doubles up on the C file rook
captures rook captures and now Queen to
d7 so as you can see the material on the
board is is equal black has the
advantage of having two points on the
Queen side so if you know things started
things start happening then that could
be definitely an advantage for black
while White has a very nice central bone
structure here it would a very advanced
pawn on d5 already
so we have Knight to c4 by white what
ideas of going to a five or as in the
game that happened f6 preventing the e5
with Knight to a5 would a lot of a lot
of tricky moves here we have King to g7
by black and now Queen comes all the way
to a3 with a lot of ideas for example
you could capture the pawn and after the
Queen captures the Queen will no longer
be guarding the night you could win the
pawn this way but you could also win it
in a few different ways so the best the
best idea for black has just moved the
night let's say a nice the b6 but here
as he Penco played a different plan he
played b6 with the idea of getting
getting rid of white knight and he most
likely he thought that okay what's
probably gonna go to c6 and then I'm
just gonna go night to c5 but here our
team have played a different plan he
played Knights to be three and now black
has problems here
for example if black makes a slow move
let's say rook to d8 or something then
you get rook the c6 just blocking the
Queen's defense of the night and now the
night will have to move for example to
c6 where you will capture it and to win
a pawn but also there are there are some
dangerous of 90 d4 the e6 check and such
so not an easy position for black this
that that's the reason why I see Banquo
after he saw that b6 maybe wasn't the
most precise idea give up the pawn
immediately he played night the c5 to
avoid any further complications we have
Knight captures pawn captures and rook
captures so here artemyev wins upon and
now black no longer has the two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side that we
discussed but okay rook to b8 black
would definitely enjoy infiltrating the
the last rank first looked the c6 with
ideas that the queen is already
attacking the e7 pawn if the rook comes
to e6 the rook can also join in on the
hunt against the e7 pawn and here black
decides there's really no point in going
all the way to the to the last rank with
rugby one check there is no way for the
Queen to actually join in the attack and
of course you don't have time for the
first play Queen to h3 check because
then Queen cap
honey seven the Queen has to keep an eye
on this so first black goes for rook to
be seven okay both rook and the Queen
guard e7 pawn and maybe now ideas like
Queen to h3 followed by rook to be one
would be possible but for the moment not
as both the White Queen and the white
rook are guarding the C 1 square so here
King to g2 guarding h3 and not allowing
any checks on the back rank and Queen to
g4 now by black going after the e4 pawn
and he'll just rook to e6 defending it
and then out with a double attack
against the e7 pawn king to f7 defending
and now comes Queen to a6 so our team
does not allow any breeding space for
for black to you know reorganize his
forces the rook is under attack and it's
not all that easy to to defend the a7
phone for example if you try something
like rook to c7 to still keep an eye on
the a 7 point then Queen to a5 attacks
the rook once you move the rope you get
Queen here and now whatever black plays
let's say h5 who wants to go g5 h for
now you will go Queen to c8 and now
you've taken all the squares away from
the from the black rook once the black
rook moves rogue b6
now you will play h3 force the Queen
back Queen g5 and now you will go Queen
to d7
where you will well simply win the game
you are forcing a trade here and also if
a black captures which he must then you
get pawn captures and the game the game
is over
so after Queen to a6 attacking the rook
AC panco try to look the b6 at least yes
he gives up upon but he manages to trade
rooks so here we have Queen captures on
a 7 now comes rook captures than D 6 D
captures and Queen captures so now we
have this Queen important endgame where
white has a passed pawn and it's a well
you know Queens and game it's a very
fast point as well so here Queen to a8
first white the defense d4 pawn put put
the Queen and this very important
diagonal so black will not be able to
harass the white king and now white is
ready to start pushing his passport we
have king to g7 by black and now comes a
for
g5 with a5 and black
also wants to create at least some
weaknesses and here before pushing
artemyev just relays h3 so now any pawn
push black makes either h4 then he will
push g4 or g4 then he will push h4 in
the game g4 happened artemiy of course
wants to keep everything on the kingside
closed so if he doesn't have any
problems
he played h4 and now comes Queen to b3
now with some ideas of perhaps creating
some perpetual checking ideas with Queen
f3 check fall by Queen d1 check or if
the King moves away from the protection
of the f2 pond and perhaps even grabbing
the f2 pawn but here first Queen to d5
everything is defend at this point is
defended this point is defended and of
course after Queen to have three check
which happened in the game King do you
want the Queen d1 check is not possible
as the Queen also guards the d1 square
so a d5 a very nice centralizing move by
a queen we have Queen to e2 by black and
now first Queen to c5 just defending
that f2 pawn also attacking the e7 pawn
and offering the e4 pawn but you don't
really gain anything by capturing this
pawn white will just continue pushing
his passport so here I see Penco tried a
5 and now we have Queen to e7 check
white will now use a few checks to
position the Queen behind the passed
pawn we have King to g6 Queen the e8
check King to h6 and now comes Queen to
a for now Artemia very nicely positions
his Queen behind the passed pawn while
also guarding again the d1 square which
which is very important
Queen to a6 just preventing it and now a
very nice maneuver you can use it in
your own games Queen before with Queen
to b6 you will be able to force the
black Queen away from from blocking your
past pawn
King to g6 is played we have Queen to b6
now forcing the Queen back 22 and now
finally a6
we have Queens that you wanna check King
to h2 no longer needed to be on the
light squares as the Queen is still
guarding the f2 pawn we have Queen
captures on e4 and now a7 here Queen to
f3 now still White has to keep an eye on
the f2 pawn
but also black is currently keeping an
eye on the a square so you cannot Queen
upon immediately so first we have Queen
- B - you have to get your queen behind
the passport while defending the f2
point from here we have king - g7 and
here Queen to d2 for some reason
artemyev doesn't go Queen to a2
immediately but first this Queen to d2
move we have King back to g6 and only
now Queen to a2 and now the promotion is
ready here I see panco blocked with
Queen to a8 and here artemiev just
played Queen to be one track and it was
in this position that under AC pink
resigned to the game and well a very
important victory for a lot of artemiev
in this European individual championship
2019 what is black resign well I'll
leave that up to you feel free to pause
the video here and try to find for
example if black just moves like the
King g7 how does how does the white not
win this now while you ponder on that I
will have a nice sip of my water so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player of Queen and pawn and games and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show of course the idea is Queen b8
you just force the Queen back and once
the Queen moves back notice that you are
no longer guarding the f2 point but it
doesn't matter you just Queen the pawn
bring another Queen into the game and
after black captures the f2 pawn with
check now your queen from a eight is
able to block check you simply block
check and now you have two queens your
opponent has one Queen that's that's
game over but I am Mississippi who do
not wait for that after Queen b1 check
he saw what was coming and he resigned
the game so like I said this is a game
from the penultimate round of the
European Championship but in the final
round Artemia face to Maxine ROG time
that game ended in a draw and of the
leading players only niels grand alias
won his game and he wanted in a
brilliant fashion and he caught up to
what the Slav artemyev but in the end I
will present you now with the final
standings as the European Championship
has ended
here it is Vladislav artemiev has won
the European individual Championship
would the same amount of points as
Neal's grand alias so two of them
basically sharing first place but I
believe tiebreaks decided that artemyev
is the winner and then okay we have in a
third spot we have Caspar puron and I
will read the sir about that I will read
all the 22 players because it's very
important the 22 players that have koala
the 22 highest well ranked players in
the European Championship 2019 have
qualified for the World Cup so one of
one of these gentlemen here will
definitely take place in the candidates
tournament at the top two players from
the World Cup qualify for the candidates
tournament and then well perhaps if they
win the tournament they will face Magnus
internet connects troll Championship
Series and perhaps one of the 22
gentlemen here will be even the next
world champion we'll see how it goes
so as fall at least over Tim MacNeil's
granadilla Scottsburg Puran maxim roach
tine ferrin's burkas David Anton
Guajardo leave you D etre misspell
ceremony see on Nicolas cushion Beth
grigory operon Elsa Farley johann
Sebastian Christian Hansen he resigned
in know he accepted a drawing the final
round in a completely winning position
he was very saddened with her because of
that
Alexander Alexandrov even cheaper in of
Powell use put in with use under AC
panco here
Artemis opponent from this game Nikita
Petrov Boris Gelfand will also be
playing in the World Cup
Benjamin will do run Alexander Brett
came Alexander overcometh and materials
Bartel those are the
22 people that will be playing in the
World Cup
perhaps you know qualified for for the
candidates tournament perhaps win it and
you know challenge Magnus Carlsen so
definitely exciting to be there
I believe and also I prepared well the
live ratings table as you can see in
number 13 there you have a lot of slow
artemyev who who won 18 point for yellow
points and is already at 2750 for
reading which is just insane so you know
few more games even maybe maybe a one
good game and he can go into the top ten
in the world so I don't see it like a
far-fetched fantasy that artemiev maybe
even wins the world cup and then joins
the candidates and then you know it's
gonna be really crazy so definitely you
know the world does have a new void
after Vladimir Kramnik resigned about
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and it's gonna be very
interesting to see where Tamia will go
from here because he's just really
killing it he won every tournament he
played this year in the in the beginning
of 2019 he won he won the Gibraltar
chess festival then he won the World
Team Championship with Russia and now he
wins the European individual
championship in Skopje so you know
definitely 2019 is his year and it can
only you know it can go worse but I'm
pretty sure it's gonna go better
how about yeah now that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Shalini was Yana Swami
Robert McLennan David Compton Malcolm
Brown and Philippa doll for a conclusion
to my channel thanks a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check
through my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and you know checking up on
what's what once again thank you all and
have an excellent rest of your Friday